es ist ein meilenstein für die
astronomie ein internationales
forschungsteam hat jetzt ein frei
treibendes schwarzes loch in der
milchstraße aufgespürt eine absolut
spektakuläre premiere denn ein einsames
schwarzes loch in der milchstraße war
den fachleuten bislang nicht bekannt wie
konnte diese entdeckung gelingen und was
verrät uns dieser spannende fund über
das mysterium schwarzer löcher
kriegstanz in future.de gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für
diesen spannenden themen vorschlag den
jakob uns über unseren tellerrand gruppe
geschickt hat der link dazu ist hier da
kriegt ja auch alle videos etwas früher
als die anderen das ist wirklich eine
ganz neue form dieses phänomens schwarze
löcher begeistert astronomen astronomen
weltweit seit jeher doch jetzt dieser
absolut spektakuläre fund erstmals
konnte ein stellares schwarzes loch
entdeckt und vermessen werden das ganz
alleine in der milchstraße unterwegs ist
dabei sind schwarze löcher von wenigen
sonnenmassen unheimlich kompliziert
nachzuweisen kein wunder denn schwarze
löcher sind so gut wie unsichtbar dabei
gibt es nur eine ausnahme denn wenn die
masse giganten staub und gas von einem
stern ansaugen der ihn besonders nahe
ist offenbaren sich die schwarzen löcher
durch die entstehende strahlung denn
hier bei regen sie ihr umfeld zum
leuchten an zudem gibt es eine weitere
möglichkeit schwarze löcher dingfest zu
machen daher machen sich forschende
zunutze dass schwarze löcher einen nicht
unwesentlichen einfluss darauf haben wie
sich benachbarte himmelskörper bewegen
dabei sind sich fachleute sicher dass
gerade die stellaren schwarzen löchern
besonders zahlreich im kosmos vorkommen
dass sich an ihrer entstehung weise denn
stellare schwarze löcher entstehen aus
massereichen sternen die kollabieren
nach ihrer bildung sind sie meist
inaktiv sie sagen kein material an dass
durch dieses verschlingen beobachtbar
würde genau das ist der grund warum es
forschungsteams weltweit kaum möglich
ist solchen schwarzen löchern auf die
schliche zu kommen doch genau das ist
jetzt offensichtlich gelungen
absolute weltpremiere wie das einsame
stellare schwarze loch endlich
aufgespürt werden konnte und was wir
bisher alles darüber wissen diese
spannenden infos bekommt ihr jetzt hier
von mir anfangen diesen jahres 2022
hatten fachleute zu genau diesem
spannenden thema berechnungen
vorgestellt demnach könnten sich im
beobachtbaren universums achtung 40
trillionen stellare schwarze löcher
verborgenheit die unglaubliche zahl
entspricht einer 4 mit 19 0 bzw
40 milliarden milliarden
modellrechnung zufolge könnten es allein
in der milchstraße etwa 100 millionen
solcher objekte seien möglicherweise
existieren in unserer kosmischen
nachbarschaft also noch viele weitere
schwerkraft giganten den italienischen
forschendes in folge sei die frage macht
der zahl der schwarzen löcher im kosmos
eine der wichtigsten und drängendsten
der astrophysik und kosmologie in ihrer
studie haben sie auf aktuelle modelle
zur entstehung und entwicklung von
sternen sowie doppelstern
zurückgegriffen berücksichtigt wurden
außerdem daten zur sternentstehungsrate
und zum interstellaren medium neben
diesen kleineren stellaren löchern die
nur etwa zehn mal so schwer sind wie
unsere sonne gibt es einen weiteren
typen die rede ist von der zweiten
gattung den supermassereichen schwarzen
löchern über deren position und bewegung
wissen fachleute weltweit ziemlich gut
bescheid sie können eine masse von einer
million bis zu 18 milliarden
sonnenmassen aufweisen ein beispiel
dafür sei die tara stern im herzen
unserer milchstraße doch neben den
kleineren stellen löchern und den
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern
könnte es sogar noch einen weiteren typ
schwarzer löcher geben die mysteriösen
intermediären schwarzen löcher mit 100
bis 100 tausend sonnenmassen der so
genannte missing link zwischen den eben
genannten kategorien doch diese
hypothese widerspricht zumindest zum
teil der bisherigen lehrmeinung laut der
sogenannten parin stabilitäts theorie
dürfte es im bereich von 65 bis 120
sonnenmassen keine schwarzen löcher
geben die erklärung dazu hängt mit der
entstehung der stellaren schwarzen
löcher zusammen die durch die supernova
eines massereichen sterns entstehen
soweit die theorie doch entdeckung aus
den vergangenen jahren haben darüber
berichtet legen immer wieder nah dass es
eben doch diese intermediären schwarzen
löcher geben könnte festhalten lässt
sich jedenfalls obwohl sich
forschungsteams weltweit intensiv mit
schwarzen löchern beschäftigen gelten
diese schwerkraftmonster wollen noch
immer als die merkwürdigsten objekte im
gesamten universum immer wieder werden
neue spektakuläre entdeckungen gemacht
doch es gibt viele weitere offene fragen
so wurden beispielsweise auch schon
einige schwarze löcher aufgespürt die
viel zu schwer sind um aus normalen
sternen entstanden zu sein wie also
kommt es zu solchen masse giganten doch
jetzt erfährt die fachwelt
möglicherweise auch bezüglich der
stellaren schwarzen löcher spannende
neue erkenntnisse in einem
internationalen forschungsteam ist eben
jetzt diese spektakuläre premiere
gelungen ein frei treibendes stellares
schwarzes loch das durch die milchstraße
zieht bislang war es forschern lediglich
gelungen kandidaten für solche objekte
aufzuspüren ein bestätigter fund in der
milchstraße dagegen der stand ist jetzt
noch aus doch jetzt hat ein stern und
der sogenannte mikro linsen effekt dazu
geführt dass das einsamste haare
schwarze loch aufgespürt werden konnte
in der fachwelt ist mit dem mikro linsen
effekt der effekt gemeint der auftritt
wenn ein objekt vor einem stern
vorbeizieht dadurch werden die
lichtstrahlen so gebogen also durch die
gravitation dass der stern uns auf der
erde dadurch vergrößert erscheint ein
objekt also die linse befindet sich vor
dem stern seine abgesonderten
lichtstrahlen werden dadurch gebogen
wodurch er von uns aus gesehen kurs habe
bereits vor elf jahren 2011 konnte genau
dieser effekt beiden sterne beobachtet
werden der sich für uns in einem sehr
dichten feld in richtung des zentrums
der milchstraße befindet laut des
aktuellen papers ist dieser sterndamm
für 270 tage deutlich heller gewesen als
in der zeit davor oder danach kurze zeit
später wurde bereits das
weltraumteleskop hubble auf dieses
ereignis gerichtet so wurde klar dass
der stern langsam wieder dunkler wurde
die messdaten verraten dem
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern viel doch die
auswertung dauert bis jetzt demnach
hatte die linse die diese aufhellung
verursacht hatte eine masse von 7,1
sonnenmassen falls es sich dabei um
einen stern gehandelt hätte hätte dieser
für die fachleute sichtbar sein müssen
er hätte leuchten müssen platz aber
nicht auch ein weißer zwerg stein oder
ein neutronenstern ist nach ansicht des
internationalen forschungsteams aufgrund
der masse als verursacher auszuschließen
selbst ein doppelsystem aus solchen
objekten käme demnach nicht auf die
errechnete masse wenn die aufhellung
doch durch ein doppelsternsystem
verursacht wurde müsste sich dann ein
schwarzes loch darin verbergen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
halten das für unwahrscheinlich einzig
und allein die erklärung mit dem
einzelnen stellaren schwarzen loch ist
plausibel dieses müsste den berechnungen
zufolge einsam in der milchstraße
unterwegs hat und sich dabei deutlich
schneller bewegen als die stern in
seiner nachbarschaft vermutlich liegt es
etwa 5200 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt wie es in dem aktuellen paper
heißt hier ist die rede von der ersten
eindeutigen entdeckung und vermessung
eines isolierten schwarzen lochs de la
ramaz dazu die wissenschaftlerin marina
bay cuba von der europäischen
südsternwarte wir können tatsächlich
beweisen dass ist isolierte schwarze
löcher gibt doch das könnte erst der
anfang sein denn die neu entwickelten
teleskope versprechen viel sie sind in
der lage tausende mikrolinsen effekte
gleichzeitig zu beobachten die fachleute
rechnen also mit vielen weiteren solcher
spannenden kunden in der zukunft dazu
sagt der astrophysiker karim el badri
der selbst nicht an der aktuellen
forschung beteiligt war das ist die
spitze des eisbergs doch zunächst steht
noch die bestätigung der aktuellen
entdeckung durch andere fachleute aus
wenn dies geschieht kann man tatsächlich
von einem meilenstein für die astronomie
sprechen denn wenn wir erst einmal mehr
über die mysteriösen stellare schwarze
löcher wissen könnte dies unsere bislang
unvollständigen theorien zur
sternentwicklung untermauern oder aber
weitere fragen aufwerfen und so am ende
unser verständnis größer werden lassen
na ja wie es in der wissenschaft halt
immer so ist eine frage wird beantwortet
zahlreiche neue stellen sich
weltraumteleskope erlauben den ersten
blick hinter einschlag doch da gibt es
noch mehr spannendes über schwarze
löcher anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran